haha oh you thought I was done talking
about doctor just because the current
season finished airing oh that's cute
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah I got stuff to do bases to cover I
have to do my overall thoughts on the
season I need to rank the episodes I am
against my better judgment gonna do a
video talking a bit about the ratings
plus there's overdue Doctor Who next
week so between all those things and
today's video I am going to be talking
about Doctor Who for the next five
videos but before we get to any of that
a bit came up in the news now this is
unconfirmed at least at the time I'm
recording this it was not 100% confirmed
but it is being reported by multiple
outlets and given the way that the
timeless child and sorry timeless
children ended I am inclined to think it
might be the case and even if it's not I
want to share my thoughts anyways so it
is looking like the characters of Graham
and Ryan are done and they will appear
in the next special which I they haven't
confirmed yet if that is gonna be
another New Year's or a Christmas
I think inclination was to move it back
to Christmas but I don't think any of
that's confirmed yet but that they are
effectively done and to jump to the end
and then explain I think that's a really
good idea now that's not because I don't
like Graham and Ryan I like them both
quite a bit Graham specially Graham has
been a highlight especially in series 11
he was one of the highlights of what was
an otherwise very uneven series and Ryan
well not a strong character on his own
again especially in season in series 11
his relationship with Graham was one of
the highlights the two of them together
had a really good dynamic and Ryan has
also kind of grown on me a bit as the
show has gone on and I've said more than
a few times basically until the second
half of series 12 started airing that
yes felt like dead weight and if they
were gonna cut anybody they should cut
her I actually now think that if they
were gonna ditch anybody ditching Graham
and Ryan and leaving just yes and the
doctor is the better move not because
yeas is in some way an inherently better
character than the other two she's not
but I think this is a good thing for the
doctor as a character basically this
comes down to three companions with a
brand new doctor was a bad idea I've
always felt it was a bad idea but I feel
like I I'm actually starting to get a
firmer grip on just why that was a bad
idea rather than just saying it felt
crowded it did feel crowded but there's
here's what here's a thing and now folks
who listen to the podcast yes there's a
council of geeks podcast they would have
heard me talk about recently the Big
Finish audio drama winter for the Adept
which is a fifth doctor they finish and
one of the tangents I got on in there
was talking about how part of why I
think I had trouble and still have
trouble connecting with the fifth doctor
is I feel like he doesn't have a
definitive companion relationship he
doesn't have the at least I haven't seen
the one relationship I'm like oh it's
through the eyes of this connection with
this companion that I better understand
the doctor because every other doctor
has that for the first doctor I would
argue that it's Susan you could also
argue it's Ian and Barbara but that
those dynamics really core essential to
his character second doctor Jamie
easy third doctors Joe grant fourth
doctor depending on your taste
it's either Sarah Jane or it's Romana
fifth doctor I like Wonder for the depth
had impaired with just Nyssa which
worked pretty well but during the show
there was Nyssa and also Tegan and I'd
like Teague him but they just share
space and they just share space with
Adric for a while so he didn't get the
chance to connect with them and have
what felt like the definitive
relationship I would also say it didn't
really happen for six during the show
but they founded his definitive
companion in Big Finish with evylyn
Smyth and then seven it was ace eight
again you
I have to go to Big Finish by default
but nine it was rows 10 I argue it's
Donna
11 it's Amy and then with 12 I argue
it's bill some people will say Clara and
13
there isn't a definitive relationship
that is defining her and the thing is I
have a certain I'm getting the 13th
Doctor better as time goes on but
there's still a certain amount of
distance between her and me much like
there's a certain amount of distance
between me and Davis and the fifth
doctor because I don't have that hook in
to be able to see that defining
relationship that gives me insight into
who they are
because that whole list I just rambled
through that's not me just showing off
like hey I remember these convenience no
the nature of those relationships the
way the doctor interacted with those
characters the way those relationships
changed if they did over time said a lot
about how that doctor was as a person it
communicated a lot about them in a way
that just them reacting to circumstances
doesn't and lacking that or having to
spread those interactions across three
characters makes that connection weaker
and it means that I'm losing insight
into the doctor and it's holding me to a
certain degree at arm's length and the
reason I think if they're going to trim
down the companions it is the best idea
to have Ryan and grim ghost because I I
feel honestly Ryan and grandma are a
package deal they they come together and
they should I mean it's not like they
share every scene together but their
relationship is such that I would have a
very hard time buying that one of them
would stay if the other left and beyond
that it would just feel odd because the
two of them like touching base all the
time was just kind of a staple
whereas yaz is much more of a solo flyer
and
I think unencumbered by Ryan and Graham
again not to imply that they were
dragging things down but they were
taking up space physically and and in
the runtime removing them so that
somebody like yaz or I mean honestly
even a new character but I would say go
with yes because I feel like there's a
building connection there having that
connection becomes stronger and clearer
and giving us the ability to zero in on
it and really see what this relationship
this specific one brings out of the
doctor whether she goes with the whether
she opens up whether she fights it
because again when it spread across
three characters it's hard to know like
the doctor seems squirrelly and
secretive but she also has to spread her
interactions across all three she can
kind of get away with well you know I'm
doing my best with all of you here if
she was being as secretive with only one
companion as she has been with all three
that would feel like a much bigger
insight into her as a person whereas you
know she's in a crowd maybe she just
can't find the time to connect and bond
with them the way that we've seen other
doctors do with other companions but you
get her with just one that excuse goes
out the window and then everything has
more meaning if she opens up we get why
cuz she's in a more intimate setting if
she doesn't open up even when she's only
got one companion there that will still
tell us a lot more than we currently
know and when I say things we don't know
I'm not talking about history and
background and lore I'm talking about as
a person about how she processes about
how she relates about how she connects
or fails to connect with people we've
had moments from the thirteenth doctor
that felt like insights I would argue
that that moment between her and Graham
at the end of can you hear me is one I
did a video about that moment
but those sorts of things have been few
and far between and I feel like the
easiest way to get more of them so that
we can get better insight on this doctor
is to trim the Companions bring it down
to one and I think he as is a good
candidate so what do you think about
this idea trimming it down and having it
be just yeas or do you think they should
keep all three do you think it's better
to keep someone other than yaz whatever
your thoughts on are on whatever I've
said drop something down the comments
let's talk about it be polite and please
stay on topic it's been an issue lately
that people on the Doctor Who comments
are dropping in on videos that are not
about something the thing they want to
complain about but they still complain
about like stay on topic please I will
delete comments I'm getting fed up with
that but in any case there's that plus
the usual things like and subscribe and
share the video and maybe check out my
patreon or Amazon wishlist or my P o box
if you want to send me something it's my
birthday this month I'll actually be be
opening everything that I get on a live
stream the Tuesday after my birthday so
you have that to look forward to you
still got time to get stuff to me
stuff started coming I haven't opened
any of it yet I'm actually quite excited
anyway enough about me because this
isn't really about me you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned what
was that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]